CRENSHAW FOUND IT BUT MAYBE
CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER HAS
AN IDEA A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
FOREIGN RELATIONS COMMITTEE, AND
CONGRESSMAN KINZINGER THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
>> HEY LISTEN DAN IS WRONG THE
CRYPT IS ACTUALLY PRETTY
CREEPY.
PETE: [LAUGHTER]
MAYBE HE UNDERSOLD IT.
SO YEAH WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
BILL?
WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL OF
THE ITEMS IN IT, NANCY PELOSI IS
STRONG ARMING HER CAUCUS TO GET
IT PASSED WHAT’S YOUR TAKE?
>> SO LOOK ALL THIS IS IS, YOU
KNOW, IT’S DISAPPOINTING,
BECAUSE WE’VE DONE FOUR OR  FIVE
CORONAVIRUS BILLS THAT ARE ALL
BIPARTISAN AND WE CAN DEBATE IT
AND WHEN IT’S ALL DONE WE DO A
BIPARTISAN THING.
THIS IS NOT THAT.
THIS IS NOVEMBER FOCUS SO WHAT
SHE WANTS TO DO, FOR INSTANCE
THERE WAS A REPEAL OF THE STATE
AND LOCAL INCOME TAX DEDUCTION
THAT GIVES HER BLUE STATE
VULNERABLE DEMOCRATS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY THAT THEY
VOTED FOR THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT
EFFECTS YOU, AND THEN BY THE WAY
YOUR OPPONENT PROBABLY WOULDN’T
HAVE, AND SO WHAT YOU’VE DONE IS
YOU’VE TAKEN A BILL THAT SHE
KNOWS IS GOING NOWHERE AND SHE’S
MADE IT A POLITICAL WEAPON FOR
NOVEMBER.
WE NEED TO RESIST, YOU KNOW,
FOLLOWING SUIT, ABUSING THIS
PANDEMIC AS POLITICAL
WEAPONS AND WE’RE DOING THAT FOR
THE MOST PART BUT THEY CAN’T
HELP THEMSELVES AND THAT’S WHAT
THAT WAS.
IT WAS A DISAPPOINTING, NOT-REAL
ATTEMPT TO GOVERN AND HELP THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT NEED IT
VERY BADLY.
JEDEDIAH: YOU KNOW, CONGRESSMAN,
HER ASSUMPTION THOUGH, IS THAT
PEOPLE WILL DO NO RESEARCH,
PEOPLE WILL JUST ASSUME OH,
REPUBLICANS MUST NOT CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE SUFFERING WITH COVID, BUT
INSTEAD, PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT THIS AND THEY’RE
AWARE OF WHAT SHE’S DONE WHICH
IS TO TRY TO PAINT SOMETHING AS
THIS IS FOR CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF, WHEN IN FACT SHE HAS
STUFFED IT WITH THIS ENTIRE LEFT
WING AGENDA SO ARE PEOPLE LIKE
NANCY PELOSI JUST CONVINCED THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE DUMB?
YOU KNOW, MAYBE.
I JUST THINK WHAT IT IS IS SHE
GETS PULLED SO FAR TO THE LEFT.
SHE ACTUALLY LOOKS MODERATE IN
COMPARISON TO SOME OF THESE NEW
DEMOCRATS.
SHE GETS PULLED SO FAR TO THE
LEFT AND SHE HAS TO APPEASE THEM
, AND YOU KNOW, UNLIKE THE
OLD DAYS WHEN WE ACTUALLY
DIDN’T HAVE A $30 TRILLION DEBT
ALMOST, SHE THINKS THAT SHE CAN
JUST AUTHOR THIS KIND OF
CHRISTMAS TREE OF WHATEVER
ANYBODY WANTS, AND I SAW HER ON
AN INTERVIEW WHERE SHE WAS KIND
OF GIGGLING ABOUT HOW BIG THIS
WAS GOING TO BE, AND YOU
KNOW, WE’RE GOING TO HAVE REAL
TOUGH DECISIONS TO MAKE WHEN THE
ECONOMY RECOVERS BECAUSE OF
OUR DEBT, AND IT’S JUST NOT A
SERIOUS ATTEMPT TO GOVERN.
LIKE THIS IS A REAL MOMENT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
BRINGING US TOGETHER, WITH
SERIOUS CONVERSATIONS, AND IT
HAS LEGISLATIVELY UP UNTIL
YESTERDAY.
IT’S DISAPPOINTING BUT THE
ADULTS HERE WILL COME IN AND
TAKE OVER IN THE SENATE AND GET
SOMETHING DONE ULTIMATELY.
GRIFF: AND CONGRESSMAN, YOU
ADULTS ALSO DO OVERSIGHT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, FOX NEWS IS
REPORTING, THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS POSSIBLY GOING TO RESTORE
PARTIAL FUNDING TO THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION AFTER PAUSE
TO INVESTIGATE THE CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE, OBVIOUSLY BY NOW, MOST
AMERICANS ARE AWARE THAT CHINA
TRIED TO CONCEAL THE OUTBREAK.
HERE IS THE TWEET WE’RE GETTING
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDING
TO ONE OF OUR HOSTS, LOU DOBBS.
SAYS LOU THIS IS JUST ONE OF THE
NUMEROUS CONCEPTS BEING
CONSIDERED UNDER WHICH WE WOULD
PAY 10% OF WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
PAYING OVER MANY YEARS, MATCHING
MUCH LOWER CHINA PAYMENTS HAVE
NOT MADE FINAL DECISION, ALL
FUNDS ARE FROZEN.
THANKS, BUT CONGRESSMAN, AS WE
KNOW, THE  WHO WAS TWEETING THIS
, HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRANSMISSION WASN’T A FACTOR
EARLY ON COST THOUSANDS UPON
MILLIONS OF CASES TO BREAK OUT.
>> YEAH, SO, I THINK IT’S
ACTUALLY AN INTERESTING CONCEPT
BECAUSE THE ISSUE WITH THE WHO,
WE DON’T WANT TO JUST ABANDON IT
AND DISBANDIT BUT WE WANT THE
HEAD OF THE WHO GONE.
HE IS ABSOLUTELY IN THE POCKET
OF CHINA AND THERE’S NO BETTER
OPPORTUNITY THAN TO SAY WE’RE
GOING TO WITHDRAW MOST OF OUR
FUNDING.
WE’LL STILL HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE BUT IF YOU WANT U.S. MONEY
YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE A
CHANGE AND WE’VE SEEN THESE
INTEL AGENCIES AROUND THE WORLD
AND IN EUROPE PARTICULARLY
SAYING IN FACT WE KNOW THAT THE
HEAD OF WHO HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH CHINA, AND
THEN, YOU KNOW, CAST A VOTE
AGAINST DECLARING THIS A
PANDEMIC, CALLED IT THE MOST
TRANSPARENT COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
BASICALLY SO WE NEED ANSWERS AND
THE ANSWER IS NOT TO DISBAND THE
WHO, BUT IT’S TO
HAVE REAL CHANGES AND TAKE OUT
CHINESE INFLUENCE AND I THINK IF
THE PRESIDENT MAKES THIS
DECISION IT MAY BE AN
INTERESTING OPPORTUNITY TO
USE THAT MONEY AS LEVERAGE FOR
CHANGE.
JEDEDIAH: CONGRESSMAN I WANT TO
SHIFT OVER TO SOME OF THE
PROTESTS THAT ARE GOING ON
PARTICULARLY IN ILLINOIS WITH
THE STATES STAY-AT-HOME ORDER
THAT’S IN PLACE UNTIL THE END OF
THE MONTH SO WHAT ARE CON STICH
WANTS SAYING TO YOU ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL THEY ARE PRETTY TICKED
OFF SO IN PERU, ILLINOIS A HOBBY
LOBBY SOMEBODY CALLED AND SAID
IT WAS OPEN SO THE POLICE HAD TO
COME AND SHUT IT DOWN AND THEY
DIDN’T STORM IT AND THEY SHOWED
UP SAYING WE’RE UNDER ORDERS TO
SHUT YOU DOWN.
HOBBY LOBBY, RIGHT?
I THINK WHAT’S HAPPENING IS YOU
HAVE PEOPLE, MY DISTRICTS MOSTLY
RURAL.
SOME TOWNS ARE LIKE 100 PEOPLE
AND THAT’S LIKE ALREADY SOCIALLY
DISTANT BUT THEY ARE BEING
TREATED AS IF THEY ARE IN A
HOTSPOT LIKE CHICAGO AND THE
GOVERNOR WHEN HE COMES OUT
AND HE THREATENS THINGS LIKE I’M
GOING TO WITHHOLD FEDERAL
FUNDING FROM THESE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, THAT MAKES PEOPLE
EVEN ANGRIER AND I THINK WHAT
THESE KIND OF LEFT WING GOVERNOR
S ARE FORGETTING IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE FREE IN AMERICA, AND
THEY WILL BE VOLUNTARILY, YOU
KNOW, TO HELP THE STOP OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT THEY DON’T WANT
TO HAVE YOUR THUMB PUT ON THEM
PARTICULARLY AFTER WE HAVE
FLATTENED THE CURVE AND WE WERE
TOLD ABOUT THAT.
PETE: CONGRESSMAN DO YOU THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD START OPENING UP
SAYING YOU CAN’T SHUT US DOWN
FOREVER MY BUSINESS WILL GO
UNDER.
>> SO I’M NOT GOING TO CALL FOR
THAT.
I’M GOING TO SAY, YOU KNOW, THAT
I THINK THAT THE STATE OF
ILLINOIS AND THE GOVERNOR NEEDS
TO MAKE EVEN MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
HIS PLAN, MAKE IT ACHIEVABLE,
AND UNDERSTAND THAT, YOU KNOW,
IF PEOPLE WEAR MASKS IN PUBLIC
AND KEEP THEIR DISTANCE, WE CAN
BASICALLY PREVENT THE SPREAD AS
MUCH AS A LOCKDOWN CAN TOO.
PETE: WE SHALL SEE.
ADAM KINZINGER, THANK YOU VERY